welcome back to CBS mornings as we
mentioned President Biden is in Poland
to mark one year since Russia launched
his full-scale invasion of Ukraine that
country is one of several in Europe now
dealing with a mass Exodus of ukrainians
fleeing the war the U.N calls it the
largest Refugee crisis of this Century
Our Charlie dagado was there as people
fled one year later he's catching up
with some of those who were forced to
leave their homes Charlie good morning
good morning Nate we all remember those
harrowing images at the train station
here in Kiev the miles of refugees
fleeing across the border and freezing
temperatures families torn apart some
never to be reunited again we need to
warn you this report contains images
some might find disturbing
fastest mass Exodus since World War II
eight million people fled the country
according to un figures while another 8
million escape to safer places within
Ukraine
the predictions were dire Kiev would
fall within three days the entire
country within weeks trains at the
Central Station overflowed for days
the speed of the invasion triggered a
mass panic with hundreds of thousands of
people fleeing for their very lives
today this is a fully functioning train
station and many of those who have left
have returned feeling it safe enough to
come home
the first missiles to pierce the heart
of the capital tore a hole in a
high-rise apartment building we rushed
out to report on it
boom to witness the damage to people and
property we return to see a lot of the
damage repaired and spoke to Tatiana
leschuk who could have lost a lot more
in her apartment if your 10 year old
daughter this is her room
your daughter's room yes 10 years old
and what happened here this room was
destroyed destroyed completely yes
completely she described how her
daughter got up early that morning and
was in the hall the blast forced the
carpet over their head she said
protecting them from glass and debris
you were very lucky yes I think the
would bless us yes she and her family
fled to Bulgaria shortly after and have
since returned although they now live in
a third floor apartment
the suburb of bucha was particularly
hard hit and when Russian forces
Advanced Eugene lopatin's family was
trapped
some people were trying to escape in the
first days they were just killed inside
their cars and we were terrified to do
it risking it on foot with a
seven-year-old daughter and an
eight-month-old baby son wasn't an
option either the bridge between uh
Butcher and Kiev it was destroyed
and there was no way to escape to Kiev
they finally made a run for it in a
convoy with friends and made it to the
Polish border
the men weren't allowed to leave
families embraced one another some for
the Last Time Eugene has since been
reunited with his family but he'll never
forget what he told his daughter that
day he said goodbye and we will see each
other someday and everything will be
okay don't worry and I told her that
light always beats the darkness so
that were my words
Eugene told us he immediately
volunteered to fight but eventually
returned to his neighborhood in bucha
after it was liberated where he joined
UNICEF to help local kids he said made
it easier when he was missing his own
family tarika yeah nice to see him
reunited but so sad for the many who
were not Charlie dagada in Ukraine thank
you